red green refactor imagine you're
sitting in a technical interview for an
entry-level web developer job
and they ask you to implement a dynamic
time warping algorithm to measure the
similarity between two sequences in
logarithmic time
instead of freaking out and wondering
what this has to do with jquery you can
just say no problem
let me write a few test cases for that
first not only will that buy you some
time
but it also makes you look like you know
what you're doing test driven
development is a technique where you
describe the behavior of your code
before you go and implement it if you
trust the science
testing will help reduce bugs and
improve the maintainability of your code
base in the long run and if you're new
to programming
knowing how to test your code is one of
the most powerful ways to level up as a
developer not only is it fun but it will
also teach you about your code in
unexpected ways and make you much better
at debugging it today's video will teach
you everything you need to know to get
started with software testing as a
developer
we'll talk about a bunch of different
testing strategies from a high level
then take a hands-on approach by
implementing unit tests from scratch
with jest
and we'll also look at end-to-end
testing with a tool called cypress
but most importantly by the end of the
video you'll learn why testing is
valuable and how to make the decision
about whether or not you should test
something because it's a practice that
walks a very fine line between being
valuable and a complete waste of time
before we get started
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe in the last video i explained
how software testing works
but if you missed it automated testing
is basically just a way to write code
that describes your requirements
and validates your main application code
now most developers i know and myself
included
generally don't start writing tests
until we have a working feature
or maybe we just don't write any tests
at all and that's especially true with
front-end development because ui
requirements tend to change frequently
but if you follow the principle of
test-driven development you'll write
your test
before you implement your actual code
and a common mantra
is red green refactor which means you
write a failing test first
red then you write some code to get it
passing green
then you go back and optimize or
refactor the code it's not always
practical to do this
but if you have a project with very
clear requirements you might find that
tdd
actually improves your productivity now
let's take a look at a bunch of
different testing strategies and see how
they add value to a code base
at the lowest level we have unit testing
where the goal is to validate the
behavior of individual functions
methods or just units of code we'll get
hands-on with unit testing in just a
minute
the next level up is integration testing
which involves testing multiple units of
code together for example
you might have a react component and a
hook to fetch something from a database
you can unit test each of these
individually but then have an
integration test to see how well they
work together
like is the component actually able to
use the hook to get the data that it
needs for the ui
from there we have end-to-end testing
which runs your app in a simulated
environment
and attempts to emulate actual user
behavior there's a really awesome tool
called cypress
that has a browser-based test runner
that allows you to program
tests where users click on buttons fill
out forms then assert that the actual
changes to the dom
or the ui are valid personally i find
end-to-end tests to be the most valuable
ones that i write
so make sure to stay tuned until the end
of this video to see cyprus in action in
my opinion these three testing
strategies are the most important ones
to know but there are a lot of other
terms that get thrown out there that you
may want to be familiar with
acceptance testing is a form of testing
that makes sure that the software meets
all of the clients requirements
then you have system testing to ensure
that everything works on
actual servers or hardware then you have
things like sanity or
smoke tests on a large application you
may have thousands of tests to run
and this can actually take a very long
time and delay everybody else's work
a smoke test runs a few of the most
important tests first to make sure the
app isn't on fire before proceeding with
the rest of the test suite
now at this point we've only looked at
functional testing but there are also
non-functional tests for things like
performance usability
and security you'll often hear terms
like stress testing
or failover testing which are used to
test the capabilities of the
infrastructure as opposed to the code
itself
now that you know what all this fancy
testing jargon means let's get our hands
dirty in javascript by pretending that
we're in an actual technical interview
we're required to implement a stack data
structure where the last item in
is the first item out it's very similar
to an array
but we have to implement it without
using a javascript array
now before we can start we need to
initialize a project and keep in mind
that you can find the source code for
this on github
i'm using veet by running the npm init
vjs
slash app command then selecting the
vanilla javascript option
that gives us a simple project to get
started in then i'll add the jest
testing framework to it by running npm
install jest which itself will be
looking for any files in your project
that end in dot test.js let's go ahead
and create a test directory
then add a testing file to it to keep
things simple i'm going to implement our
code and also test it
in the stack.test.js file now to run the
code in this file
we need to execute the js testrunner we
can do that by going to our package.json
and setting up a new npm script called
test
that runs the jess command in addition
i'll add the watch all command
to have just watch our code in the
background and rerun the test anytime it
changes
and also the verbose flag to add some
extra output to the terminal
go ahead and run npm test from the
command line and you should get your
first failing test
because it's detecting that file but we
haven't actually written any code there
yet
one other optional but highly
recommended thing we can do here is add
types to the project
to give us intellisense for all the
matchers built into jest
install the types using npm then create
a jsconfig.json file
that has a type acquisition property for
jest this will allow vs code to provide
intellisense for everything built into
jest making your life way easier
one other random pro tip i'll throw out
there is that you may also want to
install the wallaby plugin it's a paid
vs code extension with a free trial
but it will tell you whether or not your
tests are passing directly in the editor
without having to look at the terminal
and that can give you a really nice
productivity boost
i'm going to use the terminal in this
video but wallaby is nice enough to
provide us with a discount so feel free
to check that out in the description
below
and now we're ready to proceed with our
interview the first thing i'll do
is use the describe function to describe
the thing it is that i'm testing which
in this case is the stack
it takes a callback function as the
second argument inside of which we can
define multiple individual tests by
using the test function
or it both of which do the exact same
thing we'll create a very simple test
suite here with only three requirements
we'll want to make sure that our stack
is created empty
that it can push items to the top and it
can also pop
or remove items from the top at this
point if we go ahead and save the file
we should get a failing test suite
because we've only described our
requirements and haven't actually
implemented any testing code yet
in some cases you may want to hold off
on the test implementation in which case
you can use the to-do method
to make the test pass while you figure
things out now let's go ahead and
implement our first test
the main goal of the first test is to
ensure that our stack can be
instantiated with a valid state
let's go ahead and instantiate a class
that doesn't exist to represent the
object that we want to test
from there we'll use expect to write an
expectation
to make sure that our code does what is
expected it should have a top property
that represents the index
of the item at the top of the stack
because it's empty when it's first
created
the value should be negative 1. 2b is a
matcher that will test the actual value
to the correct value now here's where
test driven development starts to get
really cool
go ahead and save the file and you'll
notice that we get a failing test
if we look at the output closely it'll
tell us exactly which line of code
failed
and why it says reference error stack is
not defined
we can use that feedback as a starting
point to start implementing our code to
address the error
we'll first need to define a class
called stack go ahead and define it
then save the file then you'll notice
that we still get a failing test
but this time it goes down to the
expectation telling us that it expected
negative one
but received undefined as the return
value to address that issue
we need to add a constructor to the
class to initialize it with the proper
data
let's give it a top value of 0 and then
we'll also define an items property here
to represent the stack itself as an
empty object because remember we're not
allowed to use arrays in this problem
go ahead and save the file and now we
finally get a passing test
you can also add multiple expectations
to a single test
let's go ahead and test the stack items
property to make sure that it's an empty
object
but when we do that you'll notice that
we now get a failing test
even though we're definitely comparing
an empty object to an empty object
and it's actually not an issue with our
implementation but an issue with the
test itself
the 2b matcher checks for referential
equality between two objects in this
case
both objects are empty but they're two
different objects in memory which is
causing the test to fail
what we need to do here is use a
different matcher the two equal matcher
would be a better choice
because it checks for value equality
instead of the object reference itself
an important takeaway here is that it's
not always your main application code
that's the problem it might be a bug in
the test itself
and unfortunately we don't write tests
for our tests now let's move on to our
second test to see if a stack can push
an item to the top
what you'll notice is that the first
thing i'm doing is initializing a new
stack
just like we did in the previous test
but there's actually a more efficient
way to do this
jest has a set of helper functions for
setup and tear down
these are really useful because code
duplication can get really bad inside of
a test suite
for example we might set up a global
variable for the stack
then use the before each hook to
re-initialize it before each new test
that'll give us an empty object to work
with before each test so we don't have
to set it up manually in each one
now going into our second test we'll
call the push method with an item
and then we'll expect the top value to
be incremented by one
and we'll add a peak property to get the
top of the stack
and we'll expect that value to equal the
value that we just pushed to it that'll
give us a failing test
and then we can once again go into our
source code and start implementing
the features needed to get to a passing
test in general what you'll want to do
here is try to get to a passing test as
soon as possible
once you have that passing test you can
then go back and refactor
and look for optimizations to make while
trying to keep your test in the green
there's just something very
psychologically satisfying when you go
from a red failing test to a green
passing test
my challenge to you is to now implement
the final requirement in the test suite
try to use test driven development to
implement a feature that can pop an item
off of the stack
speaking of psychologically satisfying
another thing you can do is run a code
coverage report
which will give you an idea of how well
your tests cover your actual source code
back in the package.json add the
coverage flag to the jest command
rerun it then you'll get this report
generated that tells you the percentage
of code
covered by your test suite that can be
useful at times but mostly it just gives
you a false sense of security
100 code coverage doesn't mean that you
have a good test suite but it may be a
good thing to show your product manager
or client
what i want to show you next is a lot
more fun and interesting and that is
end-to-end testing
unlike a unit test which is designed to
be fast and simple
an end-to-end test is very long and
complex and takes a while to run
because it simulates actual user
behaviors in the browser
we could write our end-to-end test with
jest utilizing the puppeteer package
however my favorite way to write
end-to-end tests is with a tool called
cypress
install it by running npm install
cypress and this will take a few minutes
because it's downloading an actual
browser that will run your tests
in a real world environment when the
installation is complete
we can go into our package.json and add
an end-to-end script
that runs the cypress open command that
should open up the testrunner which
comes with a bunch of built-in examples
if you click on the actions example
you'll notice it starts running a test
suite by filling out a form
clicking on buttons and doing all kinds
of other stuff when i use cypress for my
own projects i use the firebase emulator
to create a mock database and mock user
authentication
which allows me to test my apps
efficiently in an environment that is
very similar to how they'll look in
production
now if we go back into our source code
you'll notice that a cypress directory
was created
we can find the source code for this
example test by going to the integration
folder
to the actions.spec file and just like
in jest
we first define a test suite then inside
of it we have multiple tests with the it
keyword
now the cool thing about cypress is that
it makes it very easy
to code these automated interactions
with your website it has a jquery like
syntax
that allows you to match a dom element
like say a form input
then type into it with whatever text you
provide you can then run expectations
with should
to ensure that it has the proper value
css style
or whatever else is important in the ui
it's a really awesome tool and i'm not
sponsored by them in any way
but i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and consider
becoming a pro member to get access to
more advanced content thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one